so um
how are they supposed to feel at two and
four with a trip to buffalo coming i
mean how look i don't know how close
you've looked at the film of the last
couple of weeks but how bad are they
right now yeah well they're struggling i
mean there's no doubt about it so hey
covet 19 threw them off there's no doubt
when you look at cam newton specifically
it's certainly throwing him off his game
yes now here's the broader picture at
least with the patriots to where if you
want to like latch onto something and go
hey the sky's not totally falling here
let's let's put it into perspective just
a little bit at least the way i see it
you know the chiefs game i still will
sit here and go if cam newton's playing
that game the way they were playing
they're going to win that game they
outplayed the chiefs that game was there
to be had i know that's a bold statement
and ifs and all that but regardless we
saw that they could hang in there with
the kansas city chiefs without them one
of their best football players the
broncos game yeah sloppy mistakes mike
it wasn't a game where i came away going
oh man the patriots just got dominated
and you know they kind of hung no i kind
of went man the patriots moved the ball
every series but they always just had
that fatal stupid mistake whether it was
the izzo fumble snap over the head cam
tip pass those type of things so i
didn't look at that game and just go oh
man i went just uh the patriots haven't
practiced denver played a solid game no
doubt about that but i wasn't like oh
man there this is really really bad now
last week you know you know i picked the
49ers that was bad that was a butt
whooping and that is the type of matchup
that i think is concerning for the
patriots as they go forward i really do
a really good running football team they
lack big people on that side of the ball
they got behind early and
that that's not their game either
because they don't have the weapons in
the drop back pass game to be able to
get into a shootout with a team like the
49ers once their offense gets rolling so
i guess what i'm saying is
it's not good i'm not ready to panic or
hit the red you know eject button yet
with new england patriots
no i look i continue to stand by my
thought that you better kill them while
you can or they're going to get you in
january when they figure it all out cam
newton's the guy who's got to get it
figured out on the offensive side of the
ball he was on weei on monday here he is
talking about his poor performance
for any type of competitor do you feel
embarrassed
yeah
yeah and and i am as as as honest as i
could possibly be right now uh but yet
it it it tells you and the first thing i
said you know to myself coming home i
said you keep playing games like that
bro
and it's going to be a permanent change
and you know so
whatever type of way that we we have to
motivate ourselves i'm i'm i'm honest
with myself so
that leaves no type of miscommunication
with others
and you know when when the change
happens you know i'm i'm stuck on the
sideline you know listening to plays and
saying to myself like listen is this
really
you know how you want to you know
do things are you this is how you want
things to be done and until
you make that step to get better as you
have been harping on these last couple
weeks then that's what it's going to be
i don't fear coaches um
i don't fear coach's stability or my
position stability more so than
controlling the locker room right and
you know performances like yesterday you
know jeopardize is like oh my god like
players talk right and i think that's
that's what it's more that that's what's
most important to me
you know that last part is very
compelling and it's very real yeah we've
talked about that before the players
know who can play the players know who
can't play and if the guy they thought
can play all of a sudden isn't playing
well they're going to be sandy said
what yeah right what's going on what the
hell what what in the hell is going on
out there yeah and and uh he's more
concerned about that than he is the
reaction of the coaching staff which is
kind of surprising well i think he
realizes the coaching staff will be
realistic about the situation they're
going to be hard they're going to coach
him and all that but they'll be able to
evaluate it for what it is yeah he wants
to make sure though he still has
you know the the voice of the locker
room can be the leader that guy because
he is that guy he holds himself to that
standard and yeah because of that people
expect specialness when it comes to cam
newton and his play that way but yeah
it's a that's a cool inside look it
shows you
you know just what he he values being a
leader and and and and leading men and
and being the voice in the locker room
of reason and whatever else the energy
of the football team so that was really
cool to see
they have to play a certain style of
football you know yeah he's out of
rhythm julian edelman is less he's not a
hundred percent he's 80 85 90 i mean he
can't really run nikhil nikhil harry
looks like
you know it's maybe a bust right now as
far as a first-round pick receiver so
there's issues there then their o-line
is a little banged up the last few weeks
mike and they ran the ball very well
against denver 49ers is a different
issue but that's how they have to play
they need to run the ball run the ball
cam newton runs it oh then the play
action and all that works you know and
then they're in a close game and that's
when bill can use his magic and really
mess with you with all his secondary
players and all of that um
i you know they have a chance to make a
run here in the next few weeks this
would be a big game this week they match
up very well with the buffalo bills
people shouldn't just go oh buffalo's
gonna beat them no buffalo can't stop
the run buffalo throws the ball every
play that fits right into new england oh
you can't stop the run great we're great
at running oh you need to throw the ball
with josh out well our secondary is
great so
we'll see where it goes from here but
i'm not like you i'm not counting them
out yet cam newton's passing numbers
have been declining game by game all
year long in the past couple of games
look at the the chart look at where he's
throwing the ball what do you glean from
this where you've got so many throws
going to the left right side of the
field yeah i i can't really say why that
would be
you know
when i when i just think about it and
look at this and just go through the
plays in my head that i've seen the last
few weeks and everything like that i
mean a lot of shallow crossers sometimes
the back goes that way
i don't know i don't have a reason for
you of why
he wouldn't be throwing the ball to the
right side i don't think there's
anything like
specifically being done that way i don't
know it must have just shook out that
way either way he's off as a passer
altogether the last two weeks too you
know just just some balls that he's
thrown there was a third down ball the
other day where you know just you just
go man cam newton doesn't miss that
throw he throws a rifle in there and i
just really feel like he's really got
off rhythm ever since the three weeks of
not playing football for a guy who
didn't play a lot of football before
that and hopefully this is the week he
kind of gets it back they're certainly
going to need him
he was asked yesterday on weei whether
he has brain fog from covid which he
said no but the fact that he wouldn't be
asked that question it gives you an idea
of how
people are grasping for any type of an
answer to explain why this guy who
looked so good relative to where he is
now right out of the gates and we
thought he would get better and better
and better and better
he's gotten worse and worse and worse
where's the bottom when can they turn it
around when will he be the guy that they
thought he was going to be
and can they find a way to fix this yeah
before they are mathematically
eliminated you know one thing that was
really jarring we we had a
a graphic yesterday on pftpm that showed
some of the historical milestones that
have been marked by this
this run
first home loss by 27 points or more
since 1998 when pete carroll was the
head coach i mean it hasn't happened
during the belichick era yeah so many
things that haven't happened since the
very early and there it is years of bill
belichick look at that consecutive
regular season home loss is 2008 all
right that's a long time but that was
the year tom brady had a torn acl okay
fine three game losing streak 2002 two
and four through six games two thousand
that was the year they finished five and
eleven belichick's first year with the
team and then losing by 27 at home 1998
i mean
this has got to be hard
for patriots fans to process it has been
a very long time since they've been less
than ordinary and i don't know what you
do as a patriots fan when you have that
thing that you've come to rely on every
single fall
you know that's going to be there for
you and i know that they've probably had
a sense of dread that it's going to end
at some point but i don't know how you
react to that i don't know how you throw
up you pivot away from that i'd say hey
we got our six super bowls i'm gonna go
forget football i'll go find some other
sport to follow there's nothing left for
me here well
i don't think they should give up on
them i don't i mean you know like you
said the terminator he's hard to die
he's unless you dip him in some hot lava
and crap he ain't gonna die all right
and you know i just look you again you
mentioned a little the schedule
everything like that
they have a chance if they could pull
off an upset here against buffalo like i
said and i think they match up very well
the jets the week after hey baltimore
that's going to be tough i expect them
to lose but then the houston texans the
cardinals the chargers i mean they have
a chance to really sit here and go they
could win five out of their next six or
at least four out of their next six
maybe you know to where they're right
back in the thick of things here and
have a chance to maybe squeak in the
playoffs because they're not a team i'd
want to mess around with in the playoffs
but yeah you know again the team that we
thought covered 19 would not affect it
affected them at the worst possible time
at the worst possible position and then
of course we can't forget all the people
that they had dropped out before the
year this is a different football team
and uh yeah they've lost their way and
they played a team last week who's
finally getting healthy and is more
talented than them and then they have a
coach who i think is the only coach in
football who can max match wits and
really put like bill belichick's brain
in the conundrum and shanahan and it all
just funneled to the perfect storm and a
big butt whooping by the 49ers
they've got to win at least three of
these next five games yeah where it's
done it's done you go two and three
right you go four and seven it's done
and then on the other side of those
they've got the back to back la trips
chargers one week
rams short week oh this is wild i i
hadn't noticed this before on their
schedule they play at the chargers on a
sunday
and then they play at the rams thursday
night surely they won't be coming back
in between who i mean i've never even
seen that organized that way usually the
team the
right is that how they usually do that i
mean doesn't usually the team that have
to travel like that you usually gets to
play at least at home the sunday before
that thursday game but you know what if
you're going to be in la anyway you may
as well go out there and get acclimated
and play at the chargers at the rams
four days apart now they're discouraging
anything other than out and back this
year because of covet but we know the
49ers spent the whole week in west
virginia earlier this year i would be
stunned if the patriots yeah i know
country back and forth with sunday
thursday games but that's going to be a
couple of tests as well because even
though the charges are two and four the
charges i think right now are better
than the patriots the charges have been
in every game they've played they could
have won every game they played they
took the chiefs to overtime you know
they've stubbed their toes at some
moments and lost games they should have
won but they've been in every single
game they've played that one's not going
to be easy the rams are going to want
yeah at least to the extent there are
guys still on the roster from a couple
of years ago a little a little semblance
of revenge against the patriots from
super bowl 53 so uh yeah not an easy run
and then you got then you got to close
out the season the tour of the afc east
dolphins bills and then jets so
look i i'm not giving up on them they're
my preseason super bowl pick from the
afc to go with the buccaneers from the
nfc feeling pretty good about tampa not
so good about the patriots but i never
abandoned ship until it's over
and it may feel like it's over but with
this team it's never over we'll see what
they can do how about a little bit
belichick before we continue to talk
about the patriots on the patriots being
bad here he is
do you feel that the team is as far off
as you guys look at this point in time
or are you confident what you've seen in
the past that this group can
rekindle what it had earlier this year
[Music]
well i'm focused on us improving and
doing doing the best that we can and
doing better than we've done so
we'll see where that puts us i don't
know but
we certainly need to improve from where
we are and
we will so we'll just have to
[Music]
like i said do it in the in the meetings
in the walk through
in film sessions and on the practice
field and
you know hopefully that
that'll translate into better forms on
sunday uh usually does
you know is it the talent is it the
coaching what is it and how much do we
look at bill belichick as the talent
evaluator and say maybe there are some
flaws there that have been covered up by
great coaching and i've said that in the
past yeah
proof that bill belichick is the
greatest coach of all time is he
overcomes his personnel mistakes sure i
think his personnel mistakes may have
caught up to him well i mean this year
certainly again we can't forget about
the the opt outs and some of those
issues they've had there
also you know to the big only two of
those guys only two of those guys really
hurt them okay well cannon hightower
patrick chung that's three right at the
top okay and then there's two and a half
all right so that that hurt but either
way
i get you the bigger thing too all right
just as far as the roster hey you know
it's it's 20 years uh you know at some
point there is gonna be a downturn
they're set up very nicely the next year
to kick everybody's butt with the way
the salary cap is so again he's always
thinking big picture too
and
you know the the the yes there's a few
guys edelman is coming to the end you
know as far as his shelf life of being a
great great receiver they messed up i
didn't kill harry but you know the days
of being able to bag on him for
uh you know miss draft picks and things
like that i i mean i think he's been
pretty strong i mean it's hard to the
guys in the secondary you know some of
these offensive linemen he's been able
to draft consistently all of that i get
it it's not the most talented football
team the thing i'll continue to go back
to is
covid19 out of the building not being
able to coach your football team hurts
the new england patriots more than
anybody the greatest weapon they have as
an organization is that evil genius we
just saw there who gives short answers
his ability to coach think outside the
box and do all of those type of things
is their greatest advantage walkthroughs
in person meetings always being on
everything and that's why he's so
confident to go we will improve because
he's finally going we will be in the
building and i will have my finger on
everything and you'll watch will be
better from here on out and i do believe
that and i think that's really hurt them
especially with all the new pieces on
the team
and to the extent that players talk i
can imagine that the players are
even more confounded by the fact that it
was cam newton who was the first one to
introduce coven 19 into the man and
sparked that two or three lost weeks
that you're still trying to recover from
and speaking of cam and this is funny i
want to mention this one stat yeah um
because when i saw how badly he played
on sunday i pulled up
the game logs from his entire career
because i wanted to see this has to be
his worst game since
2011 or 2012 or maybe he's never had a
game this bad
he's actually had six games in his
career with no touchdowns and three
interceptions he is two away from the
all-time record congratulations john
brody
carrie collins
bob griese
norm snead wow and chris sims all hold
that record
i didn't play enough games to throw
three interceptions
i could have got there i was gonna try
to keep the straight faces i would have
got there if they just
damn spleen didn't break i would have
got there but uh yeah i thought let me
tell you full disclosure
i thought about saying phil sims just to
see but that would probably have made
you more it would have i would have been
all over that too and i'd be like no
that's not true there's no way you could
talk all the crap you want about me as a
player but when you go on a big fill i'm
gonna get ready all right so i'm not
shocked to hear or i mean a shocking
stat but the one thing with cam the way
he's always played he's aggressive he
stands in the pocket a long time and
he's not a politician when it comes to
the end of the football game you know
you we talk about this a lot he when
they're down by 17 points he still makes
throws to try to win and come back and
win the game and that leads to
interceptions and things like that
instead of yeah he could check it down
and go nine for nine in the fourth
quarter and get 120 yards and give his
chance no chance to win and come away
and you go oh well we we can't we can't
blame cam newton look his stats are
pretty good no he just he's not that way
and you know that comes back to bite you
in your butt sometime and of course you
know he's had a little issues of
accuracy here and there too throughout
his career
well and and we'll see how he responds
to getting pulled from the game yeah he
sounds resolute he's determined and he's
ready to turn it around and big test
this week cam newton josh allen and as
you said and i believe you you look
we've seen the bills all year long they
can't run the ball they can't stop the
run i'm amazed the bills aren't looking
at doing something to enhance their
their running game right at the trade
deadline yeah they need to do something
um there's not like there's a ton of
guys out there desean mccoy as we said
earlier may be available i have a
feeling the bills will not be trading
for lesean mccoy but there's got to be
something they can do there's got to be
some deal they can make to try to make
that that running game better or they
are not going to be
a a true contender there's still going
to be a gap between them and the teams
the four teams that have emerged the
best in the afc the titans the ravens
the steelers and the chief
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports